[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire ou pour la première fois
depuis plus d'un an je ne suis pas seul
j'ai invité avec moi c'est l'historien
sébastien ledoux avec qui nous allons
passer toute cette émission dans la
nation en récit qui vient de paraître
chez belin il nous raconte comment le
récit national s'est imposé dans les
débats politiques et médiatiques depuis
une cinquantaine d'années à quel point
il s'est métamorphosé notre récit
national comme on est passé de la
célébration des héros à celle des
victimes de la commémoration des
victoires de la france à la
commémoration de ces crimes
comment cela s'est il opéré c'est ce que
l'on va voir mais d'abord une image
symbolisant notre époque
voici celles que vous avez choisi
sébastien qu'est ce qu'elle représente
et bien c'est un graphe de dunes à
l'artiste américain au bay qui l'a
réalisé on est quelques temps après les
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 qui se
sont donc déroulées à paris en seine
saint denis et donc il fait une sorte de
don artistique donc pour la ville de
paris qui a été endeuillée et je trouve
déjà d'un point de vue esthétique
extrêmement fort ce geste est très beau
très réussi et puis évidemment on est là
avec la devise républicaine qui passe
par un artiste américain ce qui est
quand même toujours intéressant et puis
et puis peut-être surtout pour moi c'est
s'est inscrit dans l'espace public c'est
à dire qu'on n'est pas dans du politique
on est avec un artiste qui décide de
faire un geste qui reste dans l'espace
public et donc pour justement pour le
public en tant que tel kobeh c'est lui
qui avait fait ou est oui yes we can
exact images logos avec barack obama
comme un bébé et ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir que un autre artiste
américain va vouloir la même chose
quelques années plus tard c'est jeff
koons avec le bouquet de tulipes
sauf qu'on va lui reprocher de vouloir
le mettre un endroit peu trop avantageux
pour lui et on va finir pas accepté le
cadeau mais à un autre endroit
mais la démarche est la même mais
décalés dans le temps oui tout à fait et
bien commençons
[Musique]
sébastien ledoux vous êtes chercheur en
histoire contemporaine à la sorbonne
enseignant à sciences po et dans la
nation récit vous montrer que c'est dans
les années soixante dix après mai 68 et
après la mort du général de gaulle au
fond que le récit national commence à se
métamorphoser l'image d'epinal d'une
france victorieuse des nazis grâce à la
résistance par exemple est mise à mal
par l'apparition du spectre de la
collaboration au cinéma avec des films
comme le chagrin et la pitié lacombe
lucien monsieur klein section spéciale
et dans les livres aussi comme un livre
comme la france de vichy de robert
paxton va complètement changer notre
notre la perspective de deux que l'on
que l'on a à ce moment là sur les sur
l'occupation 1
c'est effectivement l'inde est l'un des
éléments de cette mise en cause
finalement de ceux du récit national
dits traditionnels que j'évoque un peu
dans les premières pages du livre le
récit traditionnel finalement c'est une
intrigue historique fondée sur la
victoire
les héros qui ont conduit à la victoire
est donc une sorte d' endettement
réalisé par le pouvoir politique bien
souvent mais personne plum pas
simplement on pense à la bataille du
rail par exemple qui rend hommage à la
résistance on est au lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale et donc en fait
qui rend une sorte de dette
je pense que c'est vraiment fondamental
de construire la question du récit
national autour de ce sentiment de
dettes et d'endettement vis-à-vis de
ceux qui ont participé à la victoire
et quand je parle de victoire c'est pas
simplement aux victoires militaires
extérieures
c'est en fait d'un point de vue
symbolique quelque chose de beaucoup
plus profond qui est la victoire de la
collectivité
la victoire de l'as delà de la vie d'une
collectivité sur la mort possible donc
on parle évidemment là par exemple sur
la seconde sur la seconde guerre
mondiale de l'occupation allemande
avec l'adhésion de finalement est ce que
la nation française va pouvoir survivre
à cette occupation par exemple est ce
que la communauté nationale française va
pouvoir survivre et se perpétue et
malgré cette collaboration
donc ce qu'on fait habituellement je
dirais pas simplement en france
d'ailleurs
on pourrait revenir là dessus mais ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on va ensuite rendre
hommage aux héros nationaux qui ont
permis cette victoire et les choses se
fissure dans les années 60 et encore
plus dans les années 70 il faut le récit
national tel qu'il est basé sur
l'endettement moral des générations
suivantes à l'égard de ceux des héros
qui ont permis qui ont permis à la
france d'être la france ça va seul
transféré finalement ça va passer des
résistants aux déportés on voit là la
fiche d'un film s'appelle les guichets
du louvre qui sort dans les années 70 il
ya toute une vague de films à ce moment
là qu'ils vont montrer les persécutions
raciales dont les juifs ont été victimes
dans la france occupée
on a parlé de monsieur klein tout à
l'heure mais là il ya les guichets du
louvre il ya les violons du bal et toute
une série de films qui sortent à ce
moment là et en fait on voit que
l'endettement moral ce transfert des
résistants les héros aux victimes
les déportés alors oui c'est à dire que
c'est un mouvement qui se met en place
dans les années soixante dix et j'irai
qui va vraiment se cristalliser dans les
années 1980 donc ça prend du temps
il ya cette mise en cause avec le
chagrin et la pitié évidemment d'une
france quand même effectivement qui a
collaboré donc qui n'est pas totalement
résistantes comme on nous l'avait
raconté la cantine est pas totalement
résistantes
même si même si bon il ya un petit
comment dire une petite clarification à
faire sur vous savez ce qu'on appelait
le mythe résistance y'a liste c'était
henri rousseau qui avait évoqué ce terme
là de mitry existentialiste en fait on
ce qu'on sait c'est que tous les
français n'ont pas forcément cru quand
même que la france était unanimement
résistante mais le discours et le récit
national qui était portée c'était bien
celui-là c'est ça qui est intéressant
alors après effectivement vous avez dans
les années 70 quelque chose qui est mise
en cause
et donc ça se passe en deux temps je
dirais déjà un premier le premier
événement et premiers éléments les
années soixante dix mises en cause du
mythe résistants donc on va produire
d'autres narration en fait qu'ils vont
mettre justement en avant la question de
la collaboration
et puis les années 1980 qui me semble
extrêmement importante dans le cas
français mais aussi dans un cadre plus
général plus mondial c'est la mise en
avant de la figure de la victime
pas simplement dans le passé mais en
fait dans le présent dans nos sociétés
et on en est pas sorti finalement dans
nos sociétés on a une centralité de la
figure de la victime qui va rejaillir
sur le passé et effectivement vient là
s'imposer la figure du déporté juif en
fait est là on est dans les années 80 et
l'endettement secret au fur et à mesure
dans ces années 80 et 90 l'endettement
va se forger autour de ces victimes là
on se perd au même moment la fin du
récit coloniale et qui a été très
importants depuis un siècle dans
république française dont il y avait il
y avait un incident nationale 2 du fait
colonial de l' empire colonial lui aussi
avec la perte de l'algérie évidemment
est abandonnée et des images comme comme
la prise de la smala d'abdelkader par
les troupes du duc d'aumale que moi
j'avais encore dans mon livre d'histoire
ça va disparaître cette image qui
rappelle énormément d'ailleurs le film
little big man avec avec du swing
hoffman convoi même moment comme quoi ça
se perd dans d'autres pays comme vous le
disiez où on voit les troupes du général
custer attaqué un village indien
exactement comme on le voit là les
femmes et les enfants étant attaqué par
des hommes à cheval avec des sabres un
truc qui ne choquait pas ça faisait
partie du récit coloniale et puis tout à
coup ça devient impossible après la
perte de l'algérie on ne peut plus
raconter ça puisqu'on l'a perdu ce qu'il
faut je pense vraiment bien comprendre
c'est que la question du récit coloniale
elle tout elle va là elle a été
structurantes et c'est pour ça qu'ils
attendent des bas depuis 40 ans
maintenant aux 50 ans sur 7 sur cette
question là elle a été structurante pour
le récit républicains pour le récit
national républicain à savoir qu'en fait
dans leur au 19e siècle je reviens un
peu
dans mon livre là-dessus en 19ème siècle
en fait ce qui ce qui se crée c'est pour
chaque état européen on va rester dans
l'échelle européenne
c'est la question quelle est la
spécificité finalement de chaque état
nation de chaque nation qu'est ce que et
donc les historiens réfléchi sur ces
questions là en france en tout cas donc
le ce qu'on appelait les historiens
libéraux jusqu'à jules michelet donc ils
vont écrire une histoire de france
est ce qu'ils vont trouver comme
particularité comme spécificité
finalement c'est que la france a un rôle
particulier à jouer dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
évidemment dans le sens d'un bien fait
dans le sens d'un rôle qui va vers le
progrès du genre humain où la france
apporte à l'univers le progrès du genre
humain on a un petit peu ça aussi dans
la version américaine north american
étasunienne dans une dimension très
universaliste comme ça avec un rôle
particulier un peu plus religieux mais
en france on a vraiment cette cet
établissement de ce récit là au début de
la troisième république et des
générations et des générations d'élèves
français vont effectivement recevoir ce
message là que finalement la france ne
domine pas pour dominer pour exploiter
mais bien pour civiliser
on est vraiment sur le cas de la
effectivement de la france comme comme
porteuse de la civilisation et tout ça
là aussi c'est pour ça que les années 70
sur le récit national sont sont très
importantes
tout ça là aussi va se fissurer après 62
et la guerre perdue 1 contre l'algérie
la fin du l'empiré colonial français
parce que là en fait on ne peut plus
mettre en avant justement ce rôle
et puis à une diminution territoriales
c'est à dire que la france le récit
national s'est constitué sur l'idée que
pour se perpétuer il fallait s'agrandir
territorialement 1 et la de gaulle va
réussir va réussir en tout cas je sais
pas ce qu'il réussit mais en tout cas va
mettre en avant une substitution de ce
récit national à travers deux choses
c'est à dire la souveraineté autour de
la dissuasion nucléaire fondamental dans
les années 1960 on à la bourre on a la
bombe donc on est souverain donc c'est
la question la souveraineté qui
évidemment
comment dire essentiel pour un état
nation et pour son récit et puis
deuxième chose c'est la construction
européenne avec le rapprochement
adenauer extérieur et là on a une élite
politique française qui effectivement
s'investit dans cette construction
européenne giscard c'est évident et
c'est ça de ne pas un récit national de
même il ya on va faire à la suite du
récit de la résistance on va faire le
récit de la collaboration
mais à la suite du récit coloniale on va
pas faire le récit de la décolonisation
ça c'est un peu un angle mort à ce
moment là il commence à y avoir des
films mais enfin c'est pas encore
vraiment c'est par la suite que ça va se
paie et vous fait remarquer aussi qu'au
même moment les figures héroïques du
passé celle là celle qu'on voit là le
duc d'aumale avec son sabre c'était le
héros d'autrefois c'est remplacé par
dans la vie des gens ordinaires au même
moment on voit apparaître des livres
comme montaillou village occitan le
cheval d'orgueil de jakez hélias et
toute la collection la vie quotidienne
chez hachette où on raconte la vie
quotidienne des citoyens des gens comme
vous et moi à la place de raconter là la
vie des rois la vie des explorateurs et
la vie des militaires c'est une
effectivement les années 70 pour ça elle
son post 68 si je puis dire un poste mai
68 c'est à dire il ya une critique de
l'état nation qui est vu comme l'état
centralisateur qui domine qui étouffe et
c'est pour ça qu'on a effectivement
cette dimension presque ethnographique
moi j'ai appelé ça aussi eu le tournant
ethnographique delà du récit national
quelque part c'est à dire que on va si
on va quand je dis on ce sont des
éditeurs ce sont des historiens ce sont
des médias les journalistes vont faire
plein de reportages sur géante est la
mémoire des du sabot pour la région
bretonne par exemple on va laisser les
hommes jack a aussi oui c'est l'état
lui-même qui l'interviewait patrimoine
afin la célébration du patrimoine dont
vous parlez c'est l'état qui le fait les
célèbres le patrimoine parce qu'on on
célèbre - les héros tout à fait l'état
va reprendre effectivement cet
engouement
pensons à la généalogie et à
l'engouement des français pour la
généalogie qui date de la fin des années
soixante dix et qui s'est jamais
démentie jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais qui
commence là où on a un retour sur soi
finalement scellé c'est vraiment
l'histoire pour soi l'histoire soit
l'histoire de son alors de soi de son
groupe de sa collectivité et on change
d'échelle
on change d celle des châles sur ce
récit national c'est pour ça que on peut
pas dire peut-être que vous y reviendrez
on peut pas dire que le récit national a
disparu mais en tout cas il a
complètement changé en quelques années
dans ces années 70 est d'ailleurs le
premier cri d'alarmé
il est poussé en 1979 par le figaro
magazine
avec alain decaux sur la couverture et
qui nous dit déjà on apprend plus
l'histoire à nos enfants
sadia que des strings ya plus de
quarante ans maintenant
on disait déjà la même chose alors vous
dites dans à l'ado quo n'était pas si en
colère que ça c'est plus la rédaction du
figaro magazine
à l'époque c'est louis pauwels yann
benoît il ya une partie de la nouvelle
droite dans le figaro magazine et qui
s'empare de ce sujet qui devient un vrai
sujet c'est le début en fait de deux ce
sujet comme un chant de controverses
publiques et on n'en est pas sorti on en
n'est pas sortie jusqu'en 2021 mais
c'est vraiment le point de départ le
point de bascule d'un sujet
l'enseignement de l'histoire qui était
sujet de débat mais j'irai dans certains
cercles professionnels d'enseignants de
pédagogue et s'était jusque là et puis
là vous avez un journal bon quand même
bien évidemment majeur au niveau de la
presse figaro magazine qui va titrer on
apprend plus l'histoire à vos enfants et
on est dans cette idée de on va poser ce
problème là comme un sujet scandaleux en
fait c'est vraiment un lien pour eux
dans le discours du figaro magazine un
objet de scandale commente comment se
fait-il qu'on n'apprend plus l'histoire
à mon enfant est effectivement
l'entretien de alain decaux est beaucoup
plus modéré que le propos d
éditorialiste du figaro magazine
toujours est il qu'en fait le politique
va reprendre au bond et de tous les
bords politiques va reprendre au monde
cette lecture là cette lecture de la
société qui n'a prendrait plus est cette
école qui n'a prendrait plus l'histoire
à ses enfants ce qui est plus ou moins
vrai en fait donc c'est aussi ça ce que
je dis c'est que les enseignants se sont
emparés de nouveaux programmes mais en
même temps continuer malgré tout à
enseigner les grandes figures héroïques
nationale le récit national continue
mais il peut plus être identique à ce
qu'il était auparavant on est obligé de
le faire évoluer et on voit bien et
c'est ce que vous racontez dans le livre
à quel point on dit toujours obligé de
le faire évoluer et à chaque fois ça
crée des mois contentement quand on
valoir à cette époque là s'il ya aussi
valéry giscard d'estaing qui est quand
même dans le collimateur parce qu'il a
voulu abolir le 8 mai la victoire sur le
nazisme
il voulait la réconciliation
franco-allemande on l'accuse d'être
atlantiste au fond on l'accuse d'abord
donné le culte de la nation et
et à la fois aussi bien sheeran que
mitterrand en fait c'est drôle et
mitterrand va faire toute sa campagne
avec un clocher derrière lui le passé et
puis ensuite le panthéon l'histoire quoi
l'histoire le passé mais de gauche de
gauche en fait c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui a été travaillé par le
historiens vincent martini à dire la
nation il ya quelques il ya eu un livre
qui est qui l'a fait partir quelques
années qui est extrêmement intéressant
et donc je reprends ccc analyse la
l'identié le thème de l'identité
nationale est mise en avant par françois
mitterrand et par la gauche donc je sais
pas du tout par la droite
c'est elle c'est ça qui est très
intéressant et on est dans cette idée
que giscard avec le libéralisme
nord-américain étasunien donc la
critique de la gauche est très forte là
dessus à ce moment là est la critique du
ps du parti socialiste aussi giscard est
en train de dilapider l'histoire
nationale
la nation et l'histoire nationale et
qu'il faut absolument reconstruire une
mémoire collective nationale auprès des
français et donc il ya toute une
politique ça fait partie de deux comment
dire du rapport du parti socialiste en
80 de son programme pour 1981 vous citez
effectivement kit symptomatique un ce
clocher donc vraiment on est sur
laquelle ac la question du terroir de
l'ancienneté de la france de son
historicité de son enracinement ya
vraiment un désir d'enraciner les
français dans une nuit dans une histoire
mitterrand ne parle pas autrement il va
effectivement dans les propositions
rita fin vouloir établir le limes qui
fait après son élection donc lui m
devient jour férié alors que giscard
avait considéré qu' il fallait dépasser
en fait c'est querelle entre france et
allemagne et qu'il fallait aller vers la
reconstruction européenne est donc là on
a on a vraiment une nation
comment dire qui redevient central je
dirais
d'une façon un peu plus traditionnelle
dans les années 1980 mais a mené par la
gauche c'est ça qui est intéressant dans
les années 80 il ya il ya
l'extermination des juifs pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale de via
absolument centrale y compris dans le
récit national c'est le procès barbie
c'est le film shoah de de danse man 2
lansman c'est le premier discours de
jacques chirac au vel d'hiv
en 1986 il n'est que premier ministre
c'est les premières lois même la
première loi mémorielle qui interdit de
nier l'existence des chambres à gaz
tout ça c'est véritablement les années
80 c'est l'installation au fond du
devoir de mémoire c'est la quenelle
l'expression je lui avait consacré un
livre précédemment jusque là on n'avait
jamais parlé de devoir de mémoire
on en avait très peu de quasiment pas
parlé effectivement et sur l'émergence
du terme devoir de mémoire il est
utilisé sur d'autres sens au début d
1,80 mais on s'aperçoit enfin mon
travail a permis de quantifier ça en
fait on s'aperçoit 4 à partir de 1985 le
devoir de noir et de plus en plus
associé à la reconnaissance de
l'extermination des juifs et de la
complicité de vichy dans cette dans les
persécutions antisémites alors là il ya
quelque chose qui s'est effectivement
qui se passe dans la société française
qui est qui et qui est fondamental cette
prise de conscience un déjà de la
dimension de d'extermination qui n'était
pas forcément perçu comme évidente
auparavant par les pales j'entends
parler français donc qu'ils avaient
entendu parler de crime de massacre et
serra mais cette dimension-là
d'extermination de tout un peuple en
tout cas de d'intention exterminatrice
de tout un peuple elle arrive elle
arrive là à travers différents vecteurs
le vecteur artistique avec culturel il
est fondamental shoah de lanzmann
c'est en 85 mais c'est surtout en 1987
justement à la fin du procès barbie
première diffusion à la télé sur tf1 5
millions téléspectateurs pendant quatre
soirées entre 22 21h et minuit
on est enfin il ya 5 millions de
téléspectateurs qu'ils découvrent parce
qu'ils n'ont pas tous forcément vu au
cinéma en 85 qui découvre le film shoah
est donc là il ya tf1 à l'époque qui est
encore dans les télévisions publiques
tout à fait tout à fait et on est tout à
la fin du procès barbie le procès barbie
évidemment l'un des commandes irlandais
l'un des apports du procès barbie c'est
les enfants d'izieu qui était un sujet
tout à fait aux cubains pas occulté mais
en tout cas inconnu auparavant des
français là aussi la rafle des enfants
d'izieu y la responsabilité évidemment
de barbie dans cette rafle a avec des
enfants 42 enfants qui ont été
exterminés
dans les chambres à gaz et donc
effectivement vous avez en ce moment là
et parallèlement à l'émergence et à la
montée du front national puisqu'il faut
pas oublier de les deux sont quand même
assez lié aussi dans un discours plus je
dirais de type à la limite du
négationnisme car justement c'est là
dessus que va se jouer différentes
différentes controverses en fait vous
avez en fait la question de du trouble à
l'ordre public va changer ce que ce que
j'entends par là ça veut dire qu'en fait
autrefois où auparavant le traitement
politique traditionnelle c'est la vni
stee eilas on le voit pour la guerre
d'algérie par exemple jusqu'en jusqu'à
mitterrand c'est l'amnistié c'est
l'amnésie
c'est de ne plus exister et c'est
l'oubli c'est dans ce que cela peut
avoir de positif à l'époque oui on
oublie exactement elle les nourrit les
querelles et dans l'idée que bon de
toute façon oui bien sûr il ya des
victimes oui bien sûr mais il ya des
souffrances mais que le temps va faire
son oeuvre
c'est vraiment cette idée majeure qui
est de dire finalement le temps va faire
son oeuvre dans le sens où on va mettre
à distance tout ça et puis les
générations vont ensuite passez donc ces
troubles l'avons vont disparaître et la
nouvelle mais je tire à de nouvelles
normes qui se met en place autour du
devoir de mémoire 1 en france mais aussi
ailleurs dans les années 80 et surtout
90 années 90 c'est que au contraire il
ne s'agit pas d'oublier
on ne peut pas oublier la souffrance est
là c'est aussi la dimension traumatique
c'est là où on va on va voir justement
de plus en plus cette notion de trauma
de traumatismes transgénérationnel et
que donc en fait on ne peut pas
on doit pas oublier surtout on est
obligé de prendre en charge
politiquement ces crimes
ouais c'est ça la nouvelle idée du
devoir de mémoire c'est vraiment que non
seulement peut pas oublier
mais en fait le politique doit prendre
en charge sa et doit le traiter mais au
même moment parallèlement au fond il ya
la figure aussi de l'immigré qui devient
centrale dans les années 80 et là aussi
il ya la montée du front national et qui
est parallèle à aux mobilisations
humanitaires qui sont très nombreuses
une en particulier on s'en souvient
c'est band aid en fait pour lutter
contre la famine en éthiopie avec la
chanson we are the world we are the
people
c'est le moment des grands concerts
humanitaires tous les chanteurs se
relève voilà le disque à l'époque
et là tout à coup on à la figure du
tiers-monde de l'immigration puisque le
tiers-monde la pauvreté du tarn fabrique
de l'immigration l'immigration ensuite
se retrouvent dans nos pays et et
l'immigré
qui hélas de tous les temps en fait
devient une partie du récit national
alors il le devient progressivement
c'est dire qu'en fait vous avez dans les
années 1980 milieu des années 80 un
orientaliste à un scientifique un
jacques berque acquis chevènement qui
est midi de 10 cases des questions
nationales cette époque là confie un
rapport pour l'enseignement justement de
des cultures et
immigré en fait principalement du
maghreb à cette époque la mer un rapport
qui va pas être suivi d'effet
véritablement on a au début des années
90 cette ce projet d'un musée de
l'histoire des migrations
mais qui va être très tardif donc en
fait pour intégrer cette part migratoire
de l'histoire française
dans le récit national en tout cas
institutionnels un ça va prendre du
temps et donc on à l'inauguration en
mais enfin l'ouverture plus exactement
en 2007 du musée ni nationale de
l'histoire de l'immigration sans le
président sarkozy fin je suis désolé je
fais un bon en avant là et qui sera
ensuite vérité alors inauguré par
françois hollande après 2012 mais la
question n'est à ce moment là on vend on
sait le moment où commence à sentir
qu'il faut y réfléchir que ce soit pour
intégrer au fond 10 immigrés dont au ca
passe partir de ce moment là qu'ils sont
là pour rester
ou au contraire pour cultiver leur
différence
là il ya des débats qui commencent mais
au fond ils entrent dans le récit
national
à ce moment là et on se rend bien compte
qu'il va falloir qu'ils y tiennent une
place une place qu'on leur donnera vous
avez raison
plus tardivement avec des livres comme
la france noire où les racines
musulmanes de la france tout ça ça va
être étudié dans les années 2000 2010
mais c'est dans les années 80 que ça
commence oui avec une politisation quand
même assez forte dans ces années là qui
fait que ce sujet est un sujet clivant
en fait d'un sujet clivant mais vous
avez des débats effectivement à cette
époque-là déjà entre l'assimilation ou
le différentialisme à faire et ce qu'il
faut par les élites politiques parler
par le pouvoir politique d'une part mais
aussi par évidemment les partis
politiques est ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut que l'immigré soit une figure qui
s'assimilent totalement et donc fasse
disparaître ses spécificités on va dire
culturales pour dire les choses
rapidement
ou est-ce qu'au contraire il faut
entretenir
ces différences on a le débat au sein de
sos racisme par exemple un qui va
d'abord milité au nom de la différence
l'époque le slogan c'est la france c'est
comme une mobylette ça marche au mélange
voilà exactement donc il va plutôt prôné
cette question des différences à
respecter et puis qui ensuite va changer
de discours mais en quelques années plus
tard on fait une pause sébastien ledoux
on se retrouve juste après on continue
ce voyage à travers les métamorphoses du
récit national
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec l'historien
sébastien ledoux qui publie la nation en
récit chez belin le récit au fond des
des métamorphoses du récit national
on l'a vu on l'a vu dans la première
partie de cette émission au fond le
moteur du récit national ça va devenir à
partir des années 90 le dévoilement
d'une vérité ou oubliés d'une vérité
occulter d'une vérité refoulé le vel
d'hiv de ce côté là est tout à fait
emblématique avec notamment le le
discours de jacques chirac cette fois-ci
président dette en 1995 où il reconnaît
la responsabilité de la france dans la
déportation des juifs français
et là on est exactement c'est ce qui
donne le ton pour la suite au fond 1
on l'a on considère qu'il ya une vérité
oubliée un crime qui que l'on a que l'on
a préféré occulter et qu'il s'agit
dorénavant de réparer oui on change
complètement d'intrigués on change
complètement d'intrigués historique
l'intrigué historique je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure effectivement sur des
décennies et depuis le depuis enfin
depuis très très longtemps en fait
depuis même des siècles on pourrait dire
s'inscrit dans la célébration des
victoires dans l'hommage aux héros est
là
on est dans un endettement envers les
victimes qui va transformer l'intriguent
historique du récit nationale puisqu'on
va porter surtout en avant et ce n'est
que le début en fait le vel d'hiv n'est
effectivement ne que quelques le là le
discours inaugural qui va ensuite en
entraîner d'autres des lois des discours
des comme des nouvelles commémorations
mais sur cette modalité la deûle
intrigue narrative de l'histoire
française qui est plutôt un endettement
envers des victimes le plus souvent
civile et ça c'est important donc on
courbe et en kit
voilà le combat tant qu'on idéalise est
et commence à être suspect à l'arrivée
de la wii on quitte en tout cas
effectivement ces figures de combattants
donc on est vraiment plus du tout dans
ce dans ce mode narratif là et
et donc ça s'est produit sur sur
quelques années mais disons qu
effectivement on va dire on ce qu'on
peut dire c'est 95
le discours de l d'yves de jacques
chirac avec donc la france ce jour là
comme y lira pas l'irréparable xterra
dont on voit bien que vous avez une
nouvelle un nouveau paradigme si je puis
dire qui se met en place
c'est que pour jacques chirac et
d'autres n'est pas tout seul puisque
c'est à sa faire relativement consensus
finalement ce discours les résidents
précédentes où les enfants presley s'y
était opposé mitterrand comme pompidou
comme de gaulle un oui c'était pas la
france qui était responsable du vel
d'hiv
alors il y avait cette dimension il y
avait cette querelle je dirais historico
juridique presqu'un et politiques aux
districts aujourd'hui de savoir si
effectivement vichy tête une parenthèse
et qu'elles n'étaient représentés pas la
france chirac a tranché en 95 pour dire
que si effectivement c'était la france
même si rajoute dans son même discours
c'est important de dire que la france
n'était pas que cela ait la france était
aussi à londres la france était aussi
dans les sables de le lit de libye c'est
donc bon c'est pas aussi univoque que ça
mais en tout cas effectivement ce qu'on
va ce qu'on va retenir c'est
là comment dire la prééminence de la des
victimes civiles et ce nouvel acte
d'endettement vis-à-vis des
ressortissants victimes juives et de
leurs descendants et évidemment de la
part donc de la nation ce qui est ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a un peu passé sous
silence la mais qui présente dans votre
livre c'est que un peu avant il ya eu 89
le bicentenaire de la révolution
et là c'est pareil on a beaucoup parlé
du génocide vendéen par exemple qui
n'avait jamais été question avant des
massacres de septembre
de toutes les victimes au fond de la
révolution on en a beaucoup plus parlé
quasiment que des révolutionnaires eux
mêmes donc la tendance elle est un peu
tout azimut da ce moment là alors en
tout pas par ap
en tout cas pas de la part du pouvoir le
pouvoir avec jean paul goude ce que je
dis effectivement c'est plutôt une
france universaliste et qui qui conduit
un petit peu l'humanité vers un
avènement des droits de l'homme dont il
ya quelque chose comme ça autour de jack
lang notamment un donc le message qu'il
veut faire passer
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que cette
dimension des crimes des victimes de
finir finalement d'un événement
historique qui n'est pas aussi héroïque
qu'on veut bien le penser et déjà est
déjà tout à fait présent la le vel d'hiv
c'est la première fois je crois qu'on va
commémorer un crime est pas une victoire
c'est les batailles pas une langue
commémore un crime
oui alors effectivement et sa date de 93
à ercé sous mitterrand mais plutôt sous
pression
mitterrand sous pression décide de faire
une inde et craie on est en février 1993
parce que vous avez un pour une
proposition de loi qui a été déposé et
il ne veut pas de débat parlementaire
sur cette question là il ne veut pas ce
qu'il veut tout simplement pas pour des
raisons qu'on connaît à travers le livre
de pierre péan etc il ne veut surtout
pas de débat parlementaire sur cette
question là donc il dit il préfère
comment dire il préfère faire un décret
sur une journée de commémoration liés
aux persécutions antisémites donc le
jour de la rafle le jour anniversaire de
la rafle du vel d'hiv et c'est le début
d'une dinde une longue série
si je puis dire d'une commémoration
dites négatives je reprends le terme de
paul du philosophe paul ricoeur un qui
va parler de commémoration négative de
commémoration négative c'est à dire
qu'effectivement on va commémorer les
cris mais pas les victoires
parce qu'il faut bien voir que de
l'endettement dont vous parliez au début
l égard des défenseurs de la patrie
on va désormais vers l'endettement l
égard des victimes de crimes et de
violences provoquées par notre pays et
qui peuvent appeler à des réparations et
qui surtout ont traumatisé non seulement
les victimes mais leurs descendants
cette idée là commence à s'installer
tant d'autres récits nationale et va
s'élargir à partir des années 2000 alors
aux esclaves et l esclavage aux esclaves
aux descendants d'esclaves mais aussi
par exemple la toute toute la propos de
la guerre d'algérie par exemple c'est la
mémoire de toutes les victimes de la
guerre d'algérie
aussi bien les soldats français mais
aussi les les populations colonisées
les pieds-noirs et rapatriés mais aussi
les harkis parce que les harkis jusque
là on les avait on les avait exclues
quasiment delà du récit national etc etc
il faut ça arrive on arrive jusqu'à
aujourd'hui avec les femmes les femmes à
leur tour demande à être réintégré dans
le récit national en tant que victime
pas toutes les femmes mais un certain
nombre de mouvements féministes
on voit bien que ça a touché le
l'entièreté quasiment de tout ce qui
avait été oubliée occulté dans notre
dans notre histoire
alors effectivement le ce qui est
frappant c'est le sait que les
reconfigurations historique se font à
travers ce prix m'a victimaire donc on
pourrait parler aussi de la première
guerre mondiale c'est à dire qu'on a
vraiment et notamment avec jacques
chirac qui fait un discours froid en 90
8 qui est assez significatif pour dire
que finalement le ces poilus et victimes
d'atroces combat et se battait pour rien
donc qui quitte à un peu anachronique
je laisse ça va assez loin c'est de ce
prime à des des figures du passé comme
des avant tout des victimes
la guerre d'algérie vous avez tout à
fait raison je pense c'est important de
le signifier c'est à dire que vous avez
un ce que j'ai appelé un vide narratif
de la part du pouvoir politique entre 62
et 99 temps comme ça fait quand même
presque pratiquement trente ans où
finalement le pouvoir politique à part
un discours de giscard d'estaing pour le
soldat inconnu à notre dame de lorette
soldat inconnu de la guerre d'algérie à
notre dame de lorette où on est toujours
dans un discours de type un peu
coloniale enfin carrément coloniale même
on n'a pas de politique
on n'a pas de politique publique de la
mémoire de la part de l'état français
sur cet événement où vous savez on
appelait ça l'événement justement exerce
alors en soit le lendemain de changer un
peu
c'est à partir de 1999 vous avez une loi
qui va reconnaître justement ces
opérations de maintien de l'ordre ou ces
événements comme la guerre d'algérie
donc on a on signifie qu effectivement
on reconnaît l'état français par le
parlement en fait par voie parlementaire
reconnaît que ce qu'il s'agit bien d'une
guerre et pas d'une opération de
maintien de l'ordre
et puis vous avez plusieurs journées de
commémoration qui voit décrété au départ
bas par jacques chirac 1 c'est lui qui
comme qui finalement un pull cette
politique mémorial mais l'entrée en fait
est là encore une fois la mise en
intrigue de cette histoire c'est la
victime
c'est à dire qu'effectivement on va
reconnaître et considérer que les
appeler été des victimes
et donc on va en faire une journée c'est
le 5 décembre qui correspond à rien au
niveau de l'histoire de la guerre
d'algérie mais c'était le 5 décembre que
jacques chirac a inauguré donc en 2002
le mémorial du quai de branly
donc destiné justement à rendre hommage
aux victimes militaires
on va considérer les harkis comme à
juste titre je remets pas en cause mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est de devoir
justement que qu'elle est qu'elle est là
l'entrée en fait par là par laquelle on
va mémo réaliser
l'état français va même organiser cette
guerre est bien les harkis on va faire
une journée de commémoration et 25
septembre
en hommage aux harkis donc victime de
l'oubli à la fois victime de l'oubli est
victime de l'abandon suite justement à
la fin de la guerre d'algérie où une
grande partie d'entre eux ont été
abandonnées et une partie ont été
massacrés en souvient d'ailleurs en
algérie on se souvient des banderoles
harkis massacrés
exactement je crois qu'on est là photo
d'ailleurs mais continuer et et alors
c'est là où on va on a quand même une
controverse assez importante en 2005
on va avoir la même du côté du
gouvernement et là on est avec la le
gouvernement raffarin cette époque là on
a une un projet de loi pour reconnaître
la contribution des rapatriés donc des
pieds noirs un des rapatriés
mais le comment dire le point d'entrée
le même c'est à dire on va on va
considérer que de par leur exil
ce sont des victimes ce sont des
victimes de l'histoire et on leur doit
réparation et dans les répondants les
réparations qu'on veut que le comment
dire les parlementaires de droite
veulent mettre en avant il y à ce fameux
article de loi qui va faire beaucoup de
bruit qui est transmettre à l'école le
rôle positif de la colonisation
mais il faut se souvenir que cet article
de loi il tombe pas du ciel c'est à dire
l'idée c'est effectivement que les
rapatriés ont été victimes et qu'on leur
doit un dédommagement on leur doit
réparation
et bien cette réparation ce sera en
partie de dire qu' ils ont fait quelque
chose de positif pendant la période
coloniale
à la fcc sur le temps très long aussi
que l' esclavage va comme ça progressez
verrez vous jusqu'à avoir une place
centrale avec une dans l'espace public
par les fêtes les commémorations là le
fait que ce soit reconnue comme une
criée que comme un crime contre
l'humanité tout ça ne se fait pas en un
jour même si l' esclavage avait toujours
été dénoncées de tout temps dans notre
récit national mais au fond ils étaient
écartés ça ne faisait
pas partie de notre histoire quasiment
et puis là tout à coup ça prend ça prend
une importance capitale jusqu'à
reconnaître le traumatisme qui peut y
avoir ni compris chez les descendants
d'esclaves
oui le point de bascule lacets 1998
c'est pas 95 vel d'hiv ses 90 2 mais
voyez en quelques années un comment le
récit national à casser complètement
transformé finalement c'est assez rapide
d'un point de vue politique c'est année
la moisson vraiment ont restructuré ce
récit national le point de bascule c'est
98 pourquoi parce qu'en fait on célèbre
le 150e anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé à ce moment là jacques
chirac fait un discours le premier
ministre mine ne l'est pas aussi on est
en période de cohabitation et le pouvoir
politique à ce moment là en place
célèbre ça d'une manière traditionnelle
c'est à dire que finalement sur cette
histoire-là de la traite de l'esclavagé
et de leurs abolitions
l'état français ne retenez qu'une chose
c'est l abolition
c'était victor schoelcher c'est ça qu'on
mettait en avant travers des statuts où
on voit donc sur les territoires
d'autres dans les territoires d'autres
maires et les statuts de victor
schoelcher comme héros donc on rejoint
la question lions même que les luttes
des esclaves eux mêmes pour se libérer
et que c'était juste les blancs qui
avaient décidé de lui très gentiment
sidéré oui les escarres exactement et
qu'il fallait finalement que les
esclaves soit redevable rock de ce geste
voilà exactement reconnaissants de ce
geste libérateur donc en 98 on a à peu
près le même la même narration jacques
chirac met en avant victor schoelcher
comme un héros effectivement qui a
libéré les esclaves extincteur mais dans
la société ultra marines et en métropole
des personnes issues de justement de
l'outre-mer vous avez une toute autre
approche
vous avez une toute autre approche qui
s'est construite c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que comme vous dites
c'est pas comme ça si jamais en un quart
de seconde qui s'est construite au
niveau des années 80-90 de considérer
que l'esclavagé a été été pour eux a
simplement un crime au départ spa salle
terme mais une sorte de
comment dire l'identité créole c'est
edouard glisser des gens comme edouard
glissant raphaël confiant
l'identité créole lit dans leur identité
s'est construite sur cette négation de
l'esclavagé de la traite sur cet oubli
de l'esclavagé de la traite sur cette
mémoire raturé c'est le terme d' edouard
glissant dans son livre qui paraît en
1981 parle de mémoire raturé et donc il
ya toute une reconstruction identitaire
autour de justement d' esclavage comme
quelque chose qui a été niée évidemment
en terme de deux violations en termes
déjà de droits humains en tant
qu'esclave mais aussi en termes d'oubli
mais aussi en termes publiés et donc la
revendication de plus en plus forte
c'est cette reconnaissance de cette
histoire-là de la traite et de
l'esclavagé et pas simplement de
l'abolition et je dirais très peu de
l'abolition est là en 1998 vous avez une
sorte de conflit qui ont une
confrontation narrative de confrontation
de deux récits complètement antagoniques
et à la fin donc avec d une marche le 23
mai à paris réunissant entre 20000 et
30000 personnes ski noir donc ce qui
n'était jamais arrivé
c'est vraiment un acte assez fort et à
la fin de l'année christiane taubira
députée de guyane qui va proposer une
loi pour reconnaître la traiter d'
esclavage comme des crimes contre
l'humanité et c'est un mouvement social
qui est lié à une confrontation et on
est en 98 et la c1 la langue on bascule
à nouveau vous voyez enfin au niveau de
la traite et l'esclavagé on va basculer
comme on l'a basculer en 95 avec jacques
chirac pour la seconde guerre mondiale
comme on va basculer pour la guerre
d'algérie au début des années 2000 à
travers les commémorations que j'ai
évoqué tout à leur fin donc tout ça se
fait en dix ans un très très peu de
temps finalement
à partir de là vous voit bien que ça ça
continue les homosexuels vont
revendiquer au fond la même chose pour
eux que l'on fait les descendants
d'esclaves ou les descendants de
déportés
et moi j'ai l'impression que ça va jusqu
aux femmes c'est à dire que tout à coup
on va voir et
des revendications ce qui concerne une
histoire qui aurait été écrite écoeurait
oublier les femmes ce qui est vrai
d'ailleurs elles ont été oubliés très
souvent et la veuve à fleurir énormément
de livres des films des documentaires
des émissions de télévision et des
programmes scolaires
par la même occasion oui bon il ya il ya
un livre de yannick ripa qui était qui
est sorti il ya quelques mois sur
justement une histoire une histoire
féminine finalement de la france depuis
la révolution française jusqu'à nos
jours dans le scolaire vous c'est un peu
plus contrastée je dirais dans le dans
le scolaire en fait dans les manuels
scolaires ce qui est ce qu'on peut faire
comme critique c'est des fois
effectivement il ya l'introduction de de
l'histoire plus de femmes mais avec des
doubles pages de dossiers qui ne sont
pas forcément obligatoire à enseigner
dire que c'est pas inscrits c'est pas
intégré dans je dirais la leçon le récit
de la leçon
c'est une sorte d'option et donc on peut
très fins qui constate c'est qu'on peut
très bien retrouver trois ou quatre ans
plus tard dans le cadre d'une réédition
ce dossier qui disparaît alors c'est un
peu voilà je dirais dents du côté
scolaire j bien encore des efforts à
faire là dessus c'est peut-être là le
dernier endroit où ça se manifeste mais
ça se manifeste partout ailleurs
l'endettement nous ont parlé et tout
azimut
on est endetté moralement ce pays est
endetté moralement par rapport à toutes
les minorités au fond que qu'elle avait
plus ou moins oubliés dans son récit
national aujourd'hui tout le monde ya sa
place et on voit bien que ça devient
conflictuel et confond aussi bien avec
nicolas sarkozy mais aussi avec d'autres
on va essayer de résoudre le problème
c'est avec toutes ces minorités qui
demandent à faire partie du récit
national ça donne un récit national
conflictuelles et donc on commence à
dire stop à la repentance top à ce
système pas cela mais au fond on n'a pas
de réponse est tout ça en tout cas pour
l'instant pas vraiment vous voyez bien
avec le président actuel emmanuel macron
à quel point c'est difficile
à quel point c'est un sujet inflammables
c'est un sujet extrêmement clivant ce
qu'on voit apparaître et donc puisque
vous citez nicolas sarkozy c'est à
partir du milieu des années 2000
et donc ça s'accélère je dirais ça se
politise considérablement avec la gueule
la campagne de sarkozy en 2007
c'est justement le sujet le comédien le
lac estion lentilles repentance la
question transitionnelle identité
nationale effectivement question de la
question de la part de la repentance va
de plus en plus dominé je dirais le
débat à partir de 2005 et surtout 2007
jusqu'à aujourd'hui où un certain nombre
d'acteurs politiques vont considérer que
toute reconnaissance de crimes de fautes
du passé du passé national est anti
national puisque en fait derrière la
question de lentilles repentance pour
ceux qui prônent justement lentilles
repentance en disant brand ça suffit un
cessez de considérer qu'en fait c'est
contre la nation que ça va contre
l'intérêt national que de reconnaître
justement ces crimes donc on est
effectivement dans un an quelque chose
de très clivée d'une façon comment dire
schématique entre droite et gauche
bien que fin ce soit un peu plus
compliqué et qu'il faut en sortir
moi il me semble qu'il faut en sortir
justement de ces débats de ces
confrontations entre anti repentance et
reconnaissance des crimes
il faut en sortir mais on voit bien
aussi elle le récit national va se
modifier aussi avec les attentats les
attentats change quelque chose
d'abord parce qu'il ya un retour de
l'héroïsation dites vous dans votre
livre
les dessinateurs de charlie massacrés en
janvier 2015 deviennent des héros
il y en aura d'autres par la suite le
professeur sa belle patte il ya
évidemment arnould beltrame
il ya comme ça des figures de héros qui
on est de nouveau besoin de mettre des
héros dans cette histoire alors je sais
pas si on a besoin de mettre des rondes
alors en tout cas l'état effectivement
son reflex et quand on dit l'état très
concrètement c'est françois hollande
et ensuite emmanuel macron le réflexe de
l'état c'est effectivement dans cette
dent comment dire dans ces attaques de
l'est de les interpréter
parce que les événements ont toujours
des schémas d'explication et
d'interprétation et de narration est en
fait ces attaques là on pense au
mercredi 7 janvier 2015 charlie hebdo on
pense au 13 novembre mais mais dès le
premier jour
comment dire le ton est donné je dirais
l'intriguent allait donner c'est une
attaque contre la france et contre la
république
alors c'est un choix du pouvoir
politique on aurait pu décider d'une
autre interprétation finalement mais
c'est cette interprétation qui va
dominer du côté du pouvoir politique
c'est de dire que ces attaques sont des
attaques faites à la france à la nation
française et donc que les victimes sont
des victimes mortes pour la france
et là on va reprendre c'est
effectivement cette intrigue narrative
des héros qu'on avait perdues pendant
les années 90
mine c'est à dire de considérer que ces
individus là et b et donc les premiers
étant les journalistes de charlie hebdo
sont mortes pour la france
donc cette catégorie qui a été créée
après la première guerre mondiale mort
pour la france donc on va rendre hommage
aux héros qui sont morts pour la france
et on va considérer enfin le pouvoir
politique va considérer qu'ils sont
morts pour la patrie pour ce sacrifice
en fait atteint donc c'est toute cette
dimension sacrificielle dans la dans la
dans l'intrigué narrative porté par le
pouvoir politique est là on va on va
rejouer ça depuis 2015 avec la médaille
donc il ya aussi maintenant une médaille
pour les victimes des attentats
terroristes qui vont être honoré à
travers cette médaille la multiplication
aussi ce que je dis c'est que ce qu'on
voit c'est là c'est une sorte d'
établissements de culture de guerre à
travers justement les hommages aux
invalides qui se sont multipliés depuis
2015 les invalides c'était des hommages
uniquement réservé aux militaires
auparavant et là en fait on voit et on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait ces hommages la
aux invalides sont maintenant destiné
aux civils elle retourne et du drapeau
le retour au fond de tout le rituel
républicain la marseillaise au tout ça
on ne pouvait en rire il ya encore pas
très longtemps et notamment les
dessinateurs de charlie hebdo
aujourd'hui ce serait très mal vue d'en
rire c'est quasiment devenu un blasphème
c'est le cas de le dire c'est un
sacrilège parce qu'il ya toute une
il ya toute une ce qu'on appelle les
valeurs républicaines qui sont soumises
qui sont revenus au fond dans le récit
national
oui il ya le pouvoir politique a remis
en scène un imaginaire un imaginaire
national autour justement de de la
notion de guerre de sacrifices
d'héroïsme c'est ça qu'on peut voir
depuis 2015 et qui était déjà en germe
avec françois hollande et je dirais
qu'il s'est accentuée avec le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron avec un
goût pour
enfin emmanuel macron ayant un goût
assez prononcé pour justement la
dimension héroïque et il s'est exprimé à
de multiples reprises sur en faisant une
analyse de la société française pour
dire qu' il manquait une sorte
d'imaginaire héroïque et que lui tu es
là pour justement apporter cet
imaginaire héroïque mais qui est ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ça fait
quelques années déjà que on entend
s'exprimer la nostalgie du roman
national on dit pas le récit on dit le
roman on va jusqu'au bout en disant oui
évidemment que c'est une fiction mais on
l'est mais cette fonction et on y tenait
et c'est très grave de l'avoir perdu
ce qu'on découvre en lisant votre livre
c'est à quel point au fond il s'est
juste métamorphosé il a toujours existé
il est toujours aussi important mais
sous des formes différentes tout
simplement parce qu'on peut pas raconter
cette histoire de la même manière en
1950 en 1970 1980 1990 soit en 2020
c'est peut pas raconter ça de la même
manière non c'est forcément le mouvement
de l'histoire c'est à dire que on est
forcément dans une retraduction du passé
qui se poursuit et qu'on ne peut pas
figé alors ce qui est vrai c'est que
vous avez un bloc narratif
on va dire entre qu'on a bien connu en
tout cas qu'on peut bien cerner à
travers l'école notamment entre la fin
du xixème siècle et les années 1960 où
là on a une intrigue que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure un cette intrigue de
considérer que la france a un rôle
particulier dans le dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
en gros sur la planète pour apporter le
progrès et c'est vraiment parce qu'on le
voit aux états unis de la même manière
pour la même époque et se métamorphoser
là aussi avec la fin du mythe du far
west avec la guerre du vietnam avec les
minorités qui rappelle que l'amérique
n'a pas toujours été la grande
démocratie qu'elle nous raconte etc etc
ça se passe quasiment dans l'est de la
même façon avec aussi la même réaction
l'amérique a great games est qu american
winter games
exactement comme on n'enseigne plus
l'histoire à nos enfants
exactement c'est à dire qu'en fait on à
l'effritement ou la mise en cause des
mythes nationaux des grands mythes
nationaux
donc évidemment le western en fait
partie
mais mais aussi avec la guerre du
vietnam quelque chose qui s'écroule
autour de ce rôle des états unis est une
façon un peu plus religieuse que là une
dimension laïque chez pour la france
mais à une dimension quand même assez
religieuse pour les états unis qui
apporterait le bien et le bonheur et le
bien contre le mal
donc ça c'est très très fort dans la
dans l'imaginaire des états unis le bien
contre le mal
et là vous avez effectivement le jeudi
va pas l'effondrement de ces mythes
nationaux parce qu'il s'effondre pas
tout à fait mais en tout cas il se
fissure considérablement
c'est la question des minorités c'est la
question des victimes dont il faut
rendre hommage et dont il faut
s'endetter
et puis et puis cette réaction depuis
les années 2000
face à ça donc face à s'être effrité
mans qui est au contraire de vouloir
sauvegarder ses mythes donc le roman
national finalement ce qu'on peut dire
c'est une sorte de volonté de restaurer
ses mythes nationaux one c'est vraiment
ça les tenants du roman national
considérant que c'est ça qui fait tenir
finalement les populations et que si on
commence à vouloir entrer dans les
reconnaissances des crimes des uns et
des autres expériences terrain en fait
tout s'effondre donc c'est une question
très intéressante
c'est une question très importante parce
que la question du récit national moi
c'est ça que j'essaie de dire dans ce
livre c'est pas simplement une question
de récits imaginaires
comment dire un peu abstraite
c'est dans la vie des gens en c'est
important s'il ya un véritable enjeu
pour eux dans la société dans laquelle
ils vivent et et dans la société dans
laquelle ils peuvent se projeter ce que
la question de l'avenir elle est
fondamentale dans le récit national la
nation en récit c'est le titre de votre
livre sébastien ledoux ça vient de
paraître chine de la merci d'avoir été
mon invité et en plus présents sur le
plateau
dans interdit d'interdire merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]